cuándo
[Música]
tensión en rusia por el regreso de
alexéi navalni el líder opositor
arribará este domingo a moscú tras
varios meses de convalecencia en
alemania donde se estaba recuperando de
un envenenamiento del que culpa al
presidente vladimir putin la justicia
rusa anunció que procederá con su
arresto tenemos reporte desde moscú
mientras el presidente electo joe biden
anunció que arrancará su gobierno con
una decena de órdenes ejecutivas
washington dc y otras ciudades
estadounidenses se encuentran en alerta
este domingo ante la convocatoria de una
manifestación armada por parte de grupos
extremistas y de ultraderecha
en guatemala las autoridades buscan
detener el avance de la caravana de
cerca de 9000 migrantes que viajan rumbo
a eeuu
policías y militares devolvieron a
cientos de ellos a honduras entretanto
el gobierno de andrés manuel lópez
obrador refuerza los controles
fronterizos para impedir su paso a
territorio mexicano
hola cómo están buenos días en américa
latina' y a todos ustedes que nos siguen
por la señal de france 24 mi nombre es
alan austria sean bienvenidos
el líder opositor ruso alexéi navalni
viaje este domingo de alemania a rusia
cuya llegada estimada en menos de tres
horas a las 17 20 hora moscú está
marcada por la incertidumbre pues sobre
él pesan amenazas casi inmediatas de
arresto planteadas por la justicia rusa
el líder opositor que acusó directamente
al presidente vladimir putin de ordenar
su envenenamiento con una sustancia
tóxica militar de la clase no [__] que
podría ser detenido por una orden de
búsqueda y captura mientras tanto
agentes de la policía rusa detuvieron en
sant petersburgo a varios activistas que
se disponían a viajar a moscú para
recibir al líder opositor desde la
capital nuestro corresponsal xavier
colás nos detalló cuáles son las causas
que enfrentaría en su posible arresto
pues ha defendido desde el principio que
la opción de quedarse en alemania nunca
estuvo sobre la mesa que rusia su país
que echa de menos moscú y que piensa
seguir luchando contra el régimen de
vladimir putin denunciando los casos de
corrupción y los abusos del poder pero
aquí tiene una condena pendiente por un
caso porque fue condenado en el año 2014
y lo que defienden los servicios
penitenciarios rusos es que navalinos no
se ha presentado para los chequeos
habituales especialmente después de su
envenenamiento los servicios
penitenciarios rusos de que son
conscientes de que desde el 22 de agosto
navalia ha estado recuperándose en el
hospital hasta el iter en berlín pero
critican que no ha hecho ninguna
comunicación formal sobre su residencia
oficial en alemania al menos hasta el
mes de noviembre aleccionaba le está
aquí condenado por un caso de corrupción
que él pudo cumplir mediante lo que en
rusia se llama la prisión suspendido una
especie de régimen abierto o prisión
condicional pero
o libertad condicional pero en el cambio
en el caso de su hermano él si tuvo que
entrar en prisión y ahora aunque desde
su plataforma están preparando una
amplia campaña de discursos y mítines la
elección a bali se expone una vez más a
volver a la cárcel en rusia
pasamos a la capital de eeuu donde el
presidente electo joe biden tiene
preparado una decena de órdenes
ejecutivas con las cuales iniciará su
gobierno este 20 de enero las medidas de
la nueva administración prometen
revertir acciones de la presidencia de
trump como el veto a los viajeros de los
países musulmanes la reincorporación al
acuerdo de parís y una ambiciosa reforma
migratoria y el uso obligatorio de la
mascarilla en los edificios federales
entre el tanto washington dc y otras
ciudades estadounidenses se encuentran
en alerta este domingo ante una
convocatoria de grupos extremistas y de
ultraderecha para una manifestación
armada
nos negamos a ser silenciados con ese
lema fue convocada una protesta armada
para el mediodía de este domingo lo que
mantiene en alerta a las autoridades de
eeuu sus organizadores la han calificado
como la manifestación armada más grande
que ocurrirá en suelo estadounidense en
la capital se prevé que vaya desde el
washington memorial hasta la casa blanca
y también hay movilizaciones convocadas
contra los capitolios de los 50 estados
de michigan virginia wisconsin y
pensilvania están entre los estados que
activaron la presencia de la guardia
nacional para reforzar la seguridad la
atención en washington dice ha hecho que
gran parte del centro quede restringido
o bloqueado al menos hasta el 21 de
enero y la alcaldía ha pedido a los
cerca de 700.000 residentes que
permanezcan en sus casas durante la
jornada de posesión de joe biden este 20
de enero
creo que vamos a volver a una nueva
normalidad
y creo que todo nuestro país tiene que
hacer frente a como nuestro aparato de
inteligencia y nuestro aparato de
seguridad a todo nivel
tiene que enfrentar una muy presente y
muy real amenaza para nuestra nación
tenemos una responsabilidad especial en
que haya una transición pacífica de
poder en nuestro país
además para el día de la juramentación
más de 31.000 efectivos de la guardia
nacional y de las agencias de seguridad
estarán encargados de proteger la
capital
este sábado unidades policiales del
capitolio arrestaron a un hombre que
intentaba entrar en el perímetro
controlado con una acreditación no
autorizada un arma de fuego y más de 500
balas pese a los reportes del fbi y de
las agencias de inteligencia sobre
posibles ataques el presidente de electo
joe biden ha asegurado sentirse seguro
de cara a la juramentación que lo
convertirá en el presidente número 46 de
eeuu miles de migrantes que viajan a pie
desde honduras eeuu fueron detenidos en
guatemala por policías y militares otros
cientos fueron devueltos a la frontera
hoy se espera que la caravana siga
adelante para alcanzar el siguiente
objetivo méxico donde el gobierno de
andrés manuel lópez obrador exhortó a
honduras a atender y contener estas
caravanas al tiempo que fortaleció
militarmente su frontera sur con
guatemala
huyen de la violencia la crisis
económica agravada por la pandemia y los
estragos dejados por los huracanes eta
idiota
son miles los hondureños que hacen parte
de esta nueva caravana partieron de san
pedro sula e ingresaron a guatemala a
través de el florido un punto fronterizo
en el que según las autoridades
rompieron dos cordones de seguridad y
las exigencias sanitarias pues muchos no
cuentan con prueba negativa de ccoo y 19
su objetivo es llegar a eeuu donde
esperan ser acogidos por la
administración de joe biden que asume la
presidencia el 20 de enero si salimos
del país no arriesga más que cualquier
cosa nos pase
pero si lo logramos llegamos a eeuu nos
dan asilo político llevamos la meta de
trabajar el problema
la familia
pero el camino se ve plagado de
obstáculos desde el viernes méxico
ordenó el despliegue de cientos de
agentes migratorios para enfrentar lo
que ha sido denominado un flujo
migratorio masivo en diciembre by then
conversó con el presidente de andrés
manuel lópez obrador y ambos resaltaron
la necesidad de estudiar posibles
estrategias para enfrentar las
migraciones masivas si estos caminantes
son acogidos por la nueva administración
se podrían generar nuevas caravanas de
lo contrario otros centroamericanos
podrían desanimarse de abandonar sus
países el departamento de justicia de
eeuu dijo que en méxico violó el tratado
de asistencia legal mutua al ser público
del expediente de la dea que realizó en
contra del ex secretario de defensa el
general retirado salvador sin fuegos la
fiscalía general mexicana publicó el
documento completo ayer con el que
termino exonerar al general aquí en eeuu
acusa de cuatro delitos de narcotráfico
y lavado de dinero por su parte del
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
argumentó que su detención perseguía
objetivos políticos electorales en eeuu
siendo el narcotráfico uno de los temas
constantes de la campaña presidencial
de la ciudad de losa y vamos ahora
noticias que deja la pandemia de el
coronavirus
el último recuento de la universidad de
oxford reporta que más de 38 millones de
dosis de vacunas contra el cob y 19 ya
han sido administradas a escala mundial
eeuu es el país con mayor cantidad con
12 millones seguido de china con 10
millones en américa latina méxico lleva
417 mil argentinas 200.000 costa rica-
24.000 y chile 18000
colombia superó por segundo día
conceptivo los 20.000 casos diarios este
sábado y registró 388 muertes la tercera
cifra más alta desde que comenzó la
pandemia en américa latina colombia es
el segundo país con más casos al rebasar
un millón 891 mil contagios y 48 mil 205
x 6 muertes
pese a los 47 jugadores aislados por
kobe 19 el abierto de australia sigue
adelante los contagiados deberán
permanecer en cuarentena estricta por 14
días sin poder salir de sus habitaciones
del hotel un hecho que amenaza su
preparación para el torneo de tenis que
inicia el 8 de febrero
en europa la noche entró en vigor el
toque de queda nacional en francia desde
las seis de la tarde el gobierno espera
que este movimiento les dé algo de
tiempo para ralentizar la propagación
del cob y 19 mientras la vacunación
continua el virus ha cobrado la vida de
70.000 personas en este país
en angoulême en el sudoeste de francia a
los propietarios de los negocios dicen
que el toque de queda a partir de las
seis de la tarde significará una pérdida
de ingresos significativa
desde las 7 hasta las 8 y media cuando
hacemos más dinero se representa en
términos de ingresos por ventas
pues unos mil euros aproximadamente
muchos propietarios están explorando
maneras de compensar este cierre
anticipado a abrir durante la hora del
almuerzo abrir los días en los que
normalmente serían sus días de descanso
y ofrecer servicios a domicilio pero
como explican estos floristas hay
todavía bastantes preguntas estamos
esperando ver cómo podemos organizar
entregas no sé si seremos capaces de
hacer entregas a domicilio un poco más
tarde habrá excepciones para la gente
que trabaja haciendo entregas a
domicilio no lo sabemos no está
demasiado claro algunos sin embargo
están tratando de entender la situación
y dicen que la medida era necesaria
yo dirijo una tienda así que vamos a
tener que cerrar más pronto nos estamos
adaptando no creo que sea una mala
medida y realmente debería extenderse
porque el virus está en todas partes
burgess el primer ministro jan castex
dijo que el país no había visto un
aumento de los casos después de las
festividades de fin de año pero aún así
impuso restricciones más severas el
toque de queda a las 6 de la tarde se
prolongará por al menos 15 días
las catedrales inglesas han pasado de
ser lugares de culto a centros de
improvisación para la vacunación contra
el coronavirus a medida que el
territorio se propone impulsar la
aplicación de vacunas a personas de más
de 70 años de edad y otros grupos
vulnerables
las personas que hacían fila para
recibir sus vacunas en salisbury
blackburn en reinounido disfrutaron de
la música de órgano y contemplaron la
arquitectura de las catedrales mientras
esperaban su vacuna contra el comic 19
fue absolutamente maravilloso me alegré
tanto en recibirla especialmente en un
escenario maravilloso como éste y me
siento un poco más segura vio por mi
cuenta así que ya sabes es importante
los decanos de estas dos poblaciones
elogiaron el papel que los centros
religiosos desempeñan en la oferta de
vacunas a la comunidad una evidencia
para los clérigos
todos los días durante 800 años dos
veces al día hemos dicho nuestras
oraciones aquí y rezamos día a día por
la curación de la nación por la salud de
la ciudad por el bienestar de nuestra
comunidad
así que ser capaz de desempeñar este
papel positivo en esta etapa de la
emergencia de salud pública es un
maravilloso regalo que espero que seamos
capaces de ofrecer y compartir
el gobierno tiene como objetivo vacunar
a los cuatro niveles de mayor riesgo los
ancianos los clínicamente vulnerables y
los trabajadores de la salud y de la
asistencia social de primera línea para
el 15 de febrero algo que requeriría más
de 2 millones de vacunaciones a la
semana hasta este sábado casi 36
millones de británicos han recibido la
primera dosis de la vacuna lo que
representa el 55 por ciento de la
población total un equipo de alpinistas
nepalíes y su historia después de
convertirse en el primero en alcanzar la
cima del pico paquistaní k2 en invierno
la segunda montaña más alta del mundo
esta proeza marca un gran logro para los
sherpas nepalíes
han conseguido lo que muchos creían
imposible ascender el k2 en pleno
invierno
el equipo de 10 alpinistas nepalíes
alcanzó los 8.611 metros de esta montaña
el sábado marcando un nuevo récord
mundial conocida como la montaña salvaje
el k2 se encuentra a lo largo de la
frontera entre china y pakistán y es la
segunda cima más alta del mundo
el equipo de sherpas aprovechó una
ventana de buen clima con temperaturas
de 50 grados bajo cero para seguir
adelante fue un momento de orgullo para
nirmal pour ya uno de los alpinistas
estamos orgullosos de formar parte de la
historia de la humanidad y mostrar que
la colaboración el trabajo en equipo y
una actitud mental positiva pueden
llevar los límites hacia todo lo que
creamos posible anteriormente por ya
había escalado todas las 14 montañas de
más de 8000 metros en tan solo 6 meses y
sin oxígeno suplementario pero el k2
está considerada como la montaña más
desafiante de todas este invierno
decenas de alpinistas se embarcaron en
un peligroso viaje esperando alcanzar la
misma proeza el sábado el montañista
español sergi mingote murió después de
sufrir una caída mientras descendía ha
habido 450 intentos de alcanzar la cima
de esta montaña pero sólo durante el
verano menos de 300 acabaron con éxito
en un terreno dominado por alpinistas
occidentales
los sherpas locales fueron vistos
durante mucho tiempo como aquellos que
ayudaban a que otros alcanzaran el éxito
el ascenso de este equipo ha sido
descrito como un día histórico para el
país y para el montañismo nepalí
gracias siguen france24
[Música]